hi my name is markiplier and I am about
to attempt something very stupid I know
I said I was gonna try this I know I
said I wasn't gonna do this I know I
said it probably was impossible but a
curious part of me decided to experiment
just experiment a little bit try a few
things here and there check things out
scope out the environment try to
remember what was you know maybe
practice a little more and in the end I
discovered that it might be possible to
beat the second level solo that does not
mean it's easy heck it may have been
done and to be fair I don't even know if
you guys are gonna say this because I if
it's not possible then or if I can't do
it or it's too difficult then I don't
know I'm gonna put the video up but in
my testing I discovered something that I
forgot about yeah yeah this is gonna be
fun
is that the key door over there does not
require an alarm and what does that mean
you may ask well the answer is quite
simple actually it means that it is in
entirely possible to complete the
objective which all it requires is that
you get 12 personnel IDs it's no longer
a thing about HS use you don't need to
get it and run away you just need to get
the IDs and then get back to the
entrance there's no alarm at the end
there it's just get it and go and there
are usually more than 12 in the map
which means that
if you can kill things quietly come and
survive one alarm event just one I think
you just need to get through one and
then you got a obviously clear
circumstance of everything that is
everywhere you could do this it's not
but it is nothing that could happen as
long as everybody decides to be nice to
me how did I miss you but I will admit
it is a heart gripping that's not even
the right terminology it is it is a not
heart pounding it's it's just a tense
situation that goes on for a long time
because this level is big and in my
testing like I didn't get close to
beating it
I will admit but I did see the path
forward and I did survive the alarm
event that I mentioned so in only purely
theoretical terms I think this is
possible in other not so theoretical
terms I've never done it always better
to cancel with a thrust than it is to
just try to swing air in my experience
but you know if you got to do what you
got to do I guess
okay there's two more where there is no
need there is no need big guy all right
we're there's two other items in here
I've only gotten the Centurion ammo and
there's one more dude somewhere in the
maze upstairs nope across the way I see
a box okay I don't have to kill the big
dude now but I do have to kill the big
do sometimes bank ooh all right that
might have been the last little dude
which would just leave Big Daddy
over there so the question do I deal
with the now or do I wait I think I'll
wait just a little bit because maybe I
shouldn't now would be the best
opportunity because I could get at least
one good hit you cannot melee a big dude
I have discovered because if you were
near him he will swipe you for 40%
damage no lie no joke 40% damage just
straight-up but I can get one I can
clunk your head and I'm out I'm out I'm
out I'm out I'm out I'm out I'm out
oh there was another one in here was
there
god damn there was wasn't there I just
heard something else
oh no maybe that was it that might have
been it okay so now I just got up pick
my miss go pick my shots miss pick my
shots his tentacle is so long and girthy
you don't want to get anywhere near Big
Daddy's tentacle he's gonna get you
yeah you know I'll fight him on a long
way no need I'm in no rush
also I switched through the pistol
because it allows me to pick my shots a
little better and it does a surprising
amount of damage if you hit get
headshots with this thing I think it's
vastly more cost-effective than any
other gun out there but usually if
things go wrong like a big crowd then I
have to switch to my combats not shotgun
and hope for the best there who but here
is the rub what I'm looking for is I'm
looking for IDs so I need 12 there are
more than 12 in this level there's a lot
more than 12 so I'm currently in zone 38
so I need to look up zone 41 41 41
Lissa's own 41 last ID zone 41 which
there are three zone 42 has wow there's
seven over in that other area that is
that is pretty good zone 43 is this
alarmed or to my right right now there
are three over there
I think that's but this is the big
kicker this door leads to zone 39 that
requires a key but it is not the same
key door as the last one in zone 39
there's two so if you count them up
that's five in these two zones for there
which is nine and three there is 12
these are randomly displaced I don't
know if there's a possibility that you
wouldn't even need to go through one of
the doors but as far as I've found you
need to get through at least three these
three doors to get the IDS that you need
there probably would be a strategy just
to like roll the dice a million times
but this I think is the clearest method
to go there you need to get through that
alarm door get to the end of that one
clear this room ahead that's not alarmed
but has a lot of dudes and a
and then grab all the keys there is
another possibility of zone 40 there's
only two over there okay so there's a
total of four beyond that key door
there's seven over there and there's
four right there the only reason I'm not
even looking up zone 44 is because
there's there is no way there is no way
there's no way I'm getting through zone
44 it's a double alarm it's not even
where there's one yet not even worth it
so the big question is that I like to
answer first is can I survive this alarm
door that that is the question and I'm
using the shotgun sentry right now
because there's not as many like doors
here that I could try to prevent people
from going through so I've found that
just having a shotgun sentry there is
surprisingly effective it's also a
shortcut you can take there yeah the
like that's that's about it I like to do
this first because I don't like to roll
the dice on the alarm door if I can get
through it later if this one if you
technically if you clear that one you
get a lot more time before the enemies
even get in this room but also it's only
one sequence hey doing lumpy but there's
only there's only one sequence so I just
like to see if I can get there and I can
take potshots because they always drop
down that ladder is the other good thing
that I found so I can take potshots as
they get there me and my sentry can help
bust them up pretty good
and then as they're doing that this will
decide where the hell it wants to put
this it's gonna be a real dick to me
isn't it okay where where why are you
kidding me
oh this is why I don't like the roll the
dice on this because if I fail this what
the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] okay I'd like to call this
get off my lawn protocol okay oh my god
are you kidding me
am I in it why am I not in it
what oh [ __ ] off oh my god okay here we
go
hi how you doing why we're oh my god you
went all that way just to do that this
is the douchiest
I've ever seen this get off my lawn
please get off okay the door's unlocked
so now it's just survival it's just one
that's the good thing that's the good
news
the the other news is that it's still a
problem can't hit my shots I'm not gonna
risk it without wrong coming in you get
a head shots with this it kills them in
one you just have to get those oh [ __ ]
forgot about you [ __ ] okay two left two
bullets left I mean
dodge dodge Oh Oh God big guy okay this
is gonna hurt
I had to I cannot if I get hit by that
big guy it is it's like way way way more
damage than just the little dudes
I cannot believe decided like that okay
big guy did you take any damage from my
sentry I'm willing to bet the answer is
gonna be no yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah long long tongue I get it I get it
I get it yep long time had gone he
doesn't really have another weak spot
his belly I've heard takes more damage
but this symbol is the same so it's not
like a crater or anything and my shotgun
sentry is completely out of ammo he did
take some damage from it okay that went
about as horribly as I could have
possibly imagined because what happened
is they were so far away and it took so
long for that to go down there why did
it come all the way down here I have no
idea that it actually ended up summoning
a second wave because the longer the
alarm goes the more waves just keep
coming and they never stop until the
alarm is off and that's why you gotta
get the alarm off but good news I
survived
and barely on the ammo left and no
shotgun stuff but I am technically alive
so that's something I could guess if you
can Lynas item they forget about you
let's ping here said all of them in here
okay so I think there were three IDs in
here first one cool there's another zone
beyond here but trust me when I say that
zone like getting through that door I've
tried it it's two alarms the room is
small you have some doors but like I
never seem to get enough ammo in my
sentry gun to be able to help pare them
down it's just bad news all around oh
god damn it
ah Frick it's too late it's too late
it's too late it's too late it's too
late damn it damn it damn it could have
gone better but
I will not complain about my luck I will
miss
I've got I really what oh my god listen
guys listen I I wish I could make an
excuse for myself but I cannot that was
just poor performance that was poor
planning even poorer execution so yeah
just bad all around what kind of stories
we dealing with in here a43 oK we've got
a good mount I've opened two I think
already so five more so that's not bad
so hopefully I can get some health and
some ammo
I need ammo so badly I cannot do this
just swing in there's some health that's
good oh I already had a med pack don't
split my snacks on me so that's good at
least they'll be full up I don't like
the idea of only going melee but I'll do
it if I have to like I guess very
dramatic
oh I didn't hear anyone click that
doesn't mean that there's no one in here
but I mean I actually looked out yeah
it's awfully quiet in here don't trust
that there we go cool we felt good good
good good good all supplies to me all
surprised me all supplies to me I just
trying to be very careful I'm sure I get
absolutely everything okay there's the
key okay
was there really no one in here I think
there's really no one in here is that
for in here to out seven boxes total in
this zone that seems about right
I got ammo century and health so that
does bode well let me just confirm that
one two three four five six seven
yep okay I got everything in here so the
reason I'm not going through that door
over there is because it's two alarm
cycles like even with mines I've tried
it with mines shotgun century works
nicely just because it allows me to run
away and then run around and then cycle
people past my shotgun sentry and just
bang for your buck it actually is pretty
damn good so uh I have a choice hello oh
yeah I I'm psyching myself out because I
see the path forward again but you know
I I have everything I need to beat this
now I have successfully six I
successfully succeed in the crisis one
so everything else is just a matter of
being careful and cautious and not
alerting any
octo Denise see there's no alarm on here
I'm gonna go through here because I just
want to see what it's like in here if
it's dense and bad and full of octo
daddies I'm not gonna I'm not gonna
worry about it but you know for now I
mean that's it I have to kill like four
four octa dudes without alerting well
that's unfortunate
all right cool man that's real cool and
all but uh I need this box good news I
don't hear the tentacle man I don't need
a siren song of the tentacles but uh
that's not ideal I de Villa Caleb Villa
right big oK we've reached the limit of
my experimentation it is foggy I'm never
gonna be able to see any of the boxes in
here it is oh my god it's foggy okay I
just gotta be calm cool collected double
check I forgot he's tall okay all I
gotta do is be calm cool and collected
those are not things that are just dead
bodies but I hate that there's so many
of them in here because I can't tell
what's a dead body you know through the
fog they did this intentionally
just like that set up here or down there
I think this is the same layout as that
other oh that's a big guy oh my god
there's three big dudes in there holy
[ __ ]
okay I thought that was just okay you
know that's fine are you guarding any
boxes okay I thought there was one in
front of me I thought that's pretty sure
stop stop stop
I mean I could deal with the big guys I
guess but my route out is blocked right
now so I'd rather not alert them because
if I if I don't have room to run I'm
going to get swatted by one of their big
meaty claws and they're going to smack
me into the next century and I will not
recover my objective is to get through
here never getting into a fight I I just
like cannot abide by a fight right now
okay bad news I have to go through the
fog to check for boxes down there I
can't see anything oh my god there's
another big guy okay you know what let's
not go that way
I can't see how am I gonna be able to
find a box extra swing was not necessary
but I did it anyway there were only two
boxes in here I don't believe that over
there and a terminal oh that is a big
shoe D shoe big shooters are fine
oh that's too big
this is it
it's fine it's fine this is fine this is
fine hey I know you love to see it okay
cool okay okay I'm actually full up on
combat shotgun that's that's fascinating
okay so there's I've had three boxes so
far what are you doing are you blocking
on me okay so there's a total of five so
there must if I don't I'm gonna sweep
this room if I don't find two more I'll
come back to this and I will attempt to
locate them yeah okay they're fine they
should be fine over there I don't hear
much other clicking happening like it
might it is it it is legitimately just
big dudes in here and nothing else I've
never seen that did we deal with that
did we come in here cuz we've beaten
this with with friends did was there
just was there just those are just no
big dudes another one another one
there's four big dudes in the other room
there's maybe five in here I can't
believe that oh my god there's another
one where's the god damn where's the
good
I might have to query these things
individually to refill I will take it
this is a tight squeeze okay I think
this is the last box nice ass who why
why why would I ramp off of that box I
just came over here for this because I'm
not coming back here so I might as well
just fill up on this get my pistol up
okay grab my mag kids and that's one two
three four five good I can go I am
leaving I am leaving
we're fine
okay okay oh my god okay all right we're
in pretty good shape
I've got a lot of med kits I might have
left a three pack med kit in there so I
got to remember that for later but yeah
this is a rough start but this is going
well it may not seem like it but this is
going well
this one's that the toughest for me
clear though yeah
there's gonna be loads of you in here
aren't there oh my god there's gonna be
loads oh yeah I know there will be kind
of see a box over there behind your head
let me stop why you are really getting
frabjous and there's no need
Almond careful calm and careful
thankfully these guys aren't clumped up
I didn't check below okay interesting
thing about the great there is that
monsters can see through that and hear
through that so I didn't even check yeah
okay med pack three uses I'm gonna hold
on to that versus this - probably gonna
switch I just for some reason I thought
that was a big arm there like an even
bigger dude what if there's an even
bigger dude is that possible I mean I've
only oh it was a big guy down that I
could have alerted the big guy with my
stupidity
yeah here Atena come on now I think this
is the last one up here
maybe not no it was not
not clear a spank the ass bank I don't
know it may not always be guaranteed I
think they have to run into a wall
afterwards which gives a little damage
no I don't know how health works in this
game it's fine I did that perfectly no
one if you don't know what's going on in
this game you will have no idea and you
will assume that everything went great
there I was just I wasn't stupid and
didn't move forward at the last second
to move the head away which has cost me
many a scout kill it's fine
hello are you alone no this is this is
actually a really good room for this
area this room has been just I mean
maybe a hundred enemies I'm not
exaggerating there's been occasions
where it's just an unbelievable amount
of enemies where is that
there's another box there's another box
two boxes right here I'm actually
halfway to my goal and it may seem like
you know this is yeah I've been going on
forever like how have I not gotten there
yet
it's don't worry the last ones are in
here I don't think he usually if he's in
that area that means he's in that one
over there and he doesn't come in here I
don't think okay seven of twelve I'm
more than halfway there
sometimes they're like right around the
corner and I can't see them and it just
ends up with me where were you where
were you
sometimes it just ends up with me
triggering an entire room and then the
Scout gets triggered and then everything
that's that's why I'm so tense is
because if anything triggers in here it
will reach that Scout of there the Scout
will call more reinforcements and then
all of this work will have been for
nothing
like I've gotten better at the game but
I don't think I could deal with a whole
room and ask out calling additional
reinforcements all by myself I don't
think I can do that maybe a scout and
what it pulls just by itself I could
definitely probably deal with but even
that's like not a guarantee thing
how many bucks if I opened in here where
am I now I've opened four so far which
is pretty good I think I've gotten hi
bud that's two down here and then the
big guy it's too close okay okay I think
that was all the little dudes down here
there may have only been four storage
containers in here
there's another area ahead there's
actually two more areas ahead but the
next one's is own so I should go back to
the jet sounded too close I should go
back to the terminal and I should check
to see how many boxes are in zone 41
list storage zone 41 there's six total
but four in here would mean two on the
next area that seems perfectly
reasonable okay
and now I just got to get this scout and
then probably I got to get the scout
that's in the next area which is all
to guarantee no no no now the question
is is he coming back in here oh yes you
butter believe he's coming back in here
alright I'm gonna wait until the next
one he's gonna step into this light and
I'm going to whack him and everything is
going to be on under Sinn féin I've done
this before
I've done this a thousand times before
dammit yeah that's right what the [ __ ]
what he steep hey moon walked away he
knew how did he know I don't know how he
knew you know how did you know how the
hell did he know yeah you
oh he's skipper this this [ __ ]
that dick this dick this dick this dick
usually if I'm near him they're like
Bobby Bo what's over here but not this
time
apparently yes he's going to no no no Oh
Frick Oh God
okay this is a big brunt there's a big
guy down there I can't go that way oh
wow wow wow
god I oh I had that I just didn't aim
high enough holy [ __ ] God oh wow
Wow okay um holy [ __ ]
okay okay okay okay okay okay okay okay
okay I'm gonna turtle the way I've
turtle before I've done this before I've
got plenty of ammo they're gonna come up
here
stay off my lawn
they're coming through that's fine
you're gonna turtle up again you're
gonna turtle up again how did that not
hit you probably because I was being
stupid
okay I know no no no no not like this
this is not how I die oh my god oh my
god there's so many
there's so many there's just so and how
goddamnit
okay good thing I got these med packs
yeah this is about as bad as it could
have been
why are you able to go that [ __ ]
Oh God Rick oh my god oh my god no oh
okay
all right okay it's fine it's fine it's
fine it's fine that dick God through you
oh my god that big guy got any land my
shot that's all I gotta do land shots
kill all route of ammo goddamn okay you
missed you didn't land your shot and
that's what you get you get dead big
guys coming in
okay it's fine
god damn it okay he's down okay you put
the part you think you're a better shot
than me yeah you seem to be it's gonna
be a long fight I would go mano-a-mano
with them but you know I don't feel like
it Oh God [ __ ] you God of course where
did you come from
yeah yeah you thanked me dude oh this
one's sneaky that's how you snuck up on
me I guess God last medpac there's more
around I just got to get to him you know
what I'm so pissed I'm gonna [ __ ] I'm
gonna [ __ ] you up you your days about to
be [ __ ] you [ __ ] [ __ ] you think
you can mess with me
[ __ ] off [ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ]
everything about you you suck ass you
think you can Emmy you cannot I am too
goddamn handsome to be messed around
with you buy this for that [ __ ] off
I'll need to watch the footage of why
that did not hit the dude on his head I
like will have to look at that because I
swear I must have been oh that guy
didn't even wake up okay good that's one
saving grace I swear I thought I had
that dude
I thought I had him
was there one more I felt like there was
one more healthkit in here but maybe I'm
mixing that up with something else
all right this room should be clear but
I'm I'm not gonna take anything for
granted at this point and I'll thank you
reloaded good okay that's actually
pretty good on ammo is not bad
cannot tell what's going on there
hopefully not too many oh wow that could
not have gone worse this this run I am
stunned I'm still alive I don't know how
but I am the big guy here what's in here
Oh
gooshie goosh I think there's a big guy
Oh yep yep yep yep no it's just another
big big Matilda to Matilda's no one to
God of course there would be I'm stunned
I don't even think I can get around I'm
stunned this is absurd okay I'm just
gonna flash real quick I can't get
around that
you son of a [ __ ] you son of a [ __ ]
okay I'm going to have to kill these
things
that's just there's no other way around
it at least I can get one good shot just
out of pure rage and when the one goes
down I'll just go mano-a-mano with the
other Matilda running running running
now
ah well there was another box there I
missed that yeah yeah okay just gonna
place this here
don't mind me we're gonna play the game
of who can hit the target oh those
things round corners better I forgot oh
boy come on sentry do me proud come on
do me proud you're not doing me proud
you're not oh my god oh my god oh my god
okay we're still getting crits even
though the head was gone is there
another critical spot oh my good you
have no torso you have nothing left
you're skin and bones just died fall
over oh my god just die already
- every single shotgun shell I have oh
my god you have nothing left to you oh
my god your stuff are you just the
world's toughest stumped you drained my
in potty and now you're dead oh my god
I am going you killed my sentry I will
kill you just fall hey an ID well you
served me well sentry those were the
toughest Matilda's in the history of the
genre
what the hell please just go easy on me
in this last room
three more all I gotta do is get three
more three more that's it three more
somewhere in this place there's three
key ID cards two more two more somewhere
in this place there's two more ID cards
and an octave Danny yeah I wanted to do
that oh my god you're over there are you
coming this way is the question
I just cannot risk another engagement
like that if I do it's like it's just
gonna be came over there's no way that I
would be able to survive it because if I
if I miss like I don't have a shotgun
sentry anymore I've got a good amount of
ammo but I don't know if that's gonna be
enough to get me through this fight if
it does so I have to sneak around I have
to kill what I can grab the IDS and just
get out of Dodge that's all that's like
he's getting closer
a psyche knows you know the AI in this
game is pretty impressive I do have to
say that the AI is fairly impressive I
will give it that where is it he's up
here somewhere where's this dude oh okay
I think I know the layout of this one
I've been in here once oh yeah okay good
there here okay I'm in zone 42 I think
now okay I don't like okay there's seven
total boxes I've opened five so there's
two more boxes all they should have in
them is the key cards that's it and then
I get out that's all there is
frick frick frick frick frick frick I
didn't realize I was surrounded by them
[ __ ]
oh my god oh my god there's so many
right here I did not realize that oh my
god are you kidding me [ __ ] he's getting
closer there's so many right here this
is absurd I see a box kiddies coming up
this way I gotta make quick progress on
these dudes I see another box dead ahead
there's another enemy right here I saw
okay last box
no there's another one what oh [ __ ]
this might be the one be the one be the
one be the one be the one okay I'll take
it you know I'll take it
[ __ ] oh my god is he coming this way oh
my god oh please do not come down this
way this is this has got to be it
visit it has to be it it has to be it
this is a speii it
what what wears
there's one more in oh my god [ __ ] off
[ __ ] off it's here this is gotta be out
is it is it is it no no no no this is it
I have it I just have to get out I just
gotta get out I just have to get out I
have to get out okay he's over there
where are those tenants God you would
you would you prick you would you would
you're not gonna give me you're not
gonna [ __ ] you son of a [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you thought you got me you thought
you got me no no no not this time not
this time no no no this is it oh my god
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh my god big guys still down there I
can't go running through there oh my god
I think I did it holy [ __ ] I've got 12
returned to the point of entrance I just
got to sit there there was no horde that
came when we did that before but you
know maybe they'll decide to throw me a
curve ball oh my god oh oh
holy [ __ ] holy [ __ ] holy [ __ ]
oh my god I'm recording right oh my god
holy hell that was the nightmare oh my
god
I did it holy [ __ ] I did it i frickin
daddy I mean I thought it was possible
going into it but like I cannot believe
I've come to the point where I can I
beat both of these levels by myself but
yeah I'm not gonna say any of these are
impossible anymore
to do solo cuz I imagine there's someone
crazy enough to actually try thank you
everybody so much for watching this has
been an adventure an extremely fun
challenge but an adventure nonetheless
so just yeah thank you everybody so much
for watching and as always see you in
the next video
bye-bye
[Music]